[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
Karl Taylor Compton lecture I want to do
a couple of things before our speaker
takes the podium I want to give a little
bit of context for the lecture and then
of course I want to provide some kind of
introduction to today's speaker the
Compton lectures were established more
than 50 years ago in 1957 and they were
established to honor one of mi t--'s
presidents Karl Taylor Compton who had
died just three years before Karl Taylor
Compton guided MIT for almost a quarter
of a century from 1930 until his death
in 1954 his first role was president
from 1930 to 1948 he then served as
chairman of the corporation our board of
trustees from 1948 to 1954 as you all
know that quarter century was a
tumultuous time in the United States it
included the Great Depression
it included a world war and then it
included an economic and intellectual
transformation of the country of which
we are the great beneficiaries today
Compton was a transformative figure in
mi t--'s history he was I like to think
of him as a constructive revolutionary
he transformed MIT and frankly he
transformed engineering and engineering
education and practice everywhere with
his passion for uniting the physical
sciences with engineering I like to
believe that he would have really loved
what's going on today between the life
sciences and engineering and in fact he
actually used the term biological
engineering though very briefly for our
department of biology but that really is
a story for another day
the Compton lectures honor his
wide-ranging intelligence and curiosity
and they were begun
let me quote from the establishing
documents to bring to MIT some of the
great minds on the world scene since
1957 this lecture series has brought to
campus voices in science technology
public affairs education in the arts
from the physicist Niels Bohr who gave
the first Compton lecture to our Senator
Edward Kennedy who spoke just last year
our speaker this afternoon will touch on
the transformative power of technology
it would be hard to choose a subject
that would have pleased president
Compton more in 1937 Compton gave a
speech that was entitled the electron
its intellectual and social significance
now remember that was 70 years ago it
was 2 years after the invention of the
FM radio and 4 years before the first
commercial television television station
was commissioned in New York yet Compton
saw in vivid ways the potential as he
put it no instance in the history of
science is so dramatic as the discovery
of the electron which within one
generation has transformed a stagnant
science of physics a descriptive science
of chemistry and a conventionalized
science of astronomy into dynamically
developing science is fraught with
intellectual adventure interrelating
interpretations and practical values
today 70 years later the electron and
it's countless progeny have so colonized
our consciousness that it's impossible
to escape their presence so we are
especially grateful for the perspective
of our speaker today who will not remind
us that life is not virtual Tom Brokaw
our speaker has such iconic status in
American life that one could hardly
imagining introducing him in any serious
way his wide-ranging accomplishments
have moved in intriguing directions and
to extraordinary depths as the longtime
managing editor and anchor of the NBC
Nightly News
he was truly an anchor for the nation a
wise
unwavering trusted voice that helped us
make sense of the world from NATO
airstrikes in the former Yugoslavia to
the vagaries of our presidential
politics to the incomprehensible facts
of September 11th yet while sounding the
voice of constancy at home he's also
been an agile and world hopping war
correspondent peripatetic seen
everywhere around the world he was the
first to conduct a one-on-one interview
with Mikhail Gorbachev and later with
Vladimir Putin he reported from the
scene of the fall of the Berlin war wall
from the Oklahoma City bombing and from
the tragedy of TWA flight 800 he may be
the only person to have earned a place
in both the National Academy of Sciences
and the television Hall of Fame he is
the forward-looking journalist who
pushed America to examine questions like
affirmative action he is the
best-selling author who also helped us
to stop and look backward to appreciate
what we owe the great generation and he
is a deeply committed environmentalist
he continues to be the most popular news
popularity the news personality in the
United States and he's also one of the
most thoughtful voices in America today
please join me in welcoming to MIT Tom
Brokaw
thank you
thank you very thank you very much let
me just say that truth in advertising
these are the only circumstances in
which I would be admitted to MIT I can
assure you of that
when I graduated from the University of
South Dakota with a degree in political
science after a rather rocky beginning
there was a legendary political science
chairman there by the name of Bill
Farber who was a kind of academic
Godfather two generations mostly of
young men in those days he looked after
us in large ways and small and
turned-out Road scholars and governors
and Senators and when I left the
institution I'm not sure what he thought
my future was going to be but I got some
insight into it when I arrived at a
certain station in life and began to be
awarded honorary degrees and when
Washington University in st. Louis
called bill to get some background as
they were preparing my Proclamation he
said well quite honestly we thought the
first degree we gave him was honorary
[Applause]
let me say at the outset what a
privilege it is to be here on this
campus I was worried that I may have to
also make an appearance across town at
that lesser-known institution where at
Harvard I have to speak more slowly and
use shorter words when I address the
student body I was actually as a high
school student recruited by Harvard as
part of their effort to have geographic
distribution I'm sure
and after the tedious application
process Harvard and its wisdom decided
that I was not worthy of the financial
aid that would be required to get me
through four years and so as I have
often reminded audiences at Harvard fair
Harvard I have enforced all these years
to wander and that wilderness reserved
for those who do not have on a Harvard
degree wondering what may have happened
to me if only I could have gotten into
Harvard and earned a degree and I
pointed out to those audience as well
that along the way I have encountered
Harvard dropouts and we have
commiserated Bill Gates and I what might
have happened if only he had stayed
there for a while I'd like to take some
time today and have more of a
conversation with you I suppose than a
formal lecture I am in awe of this
institution and young people who are
admitted here and study here and this
extraordinary faculty administration
that you have on the work that you're
doing not just for the institution or
for the students but on behalf of the
nation and I know that you especially at
MIT are in the intersection of this
exciting new era that we're all sharing
in the era of information technology the
power of the personal computer and the
reach of the internet but let me if I
can offer some observations that may
help us all keep it in I
hope some context let me be clear about
something at the outset I'm not here to
write new code to design new apps to
build a network or even wire this room
well I am a prolific user of IT and have
been since its inception the inner
workings remain an opaque mystery to me
I approach it as I do my primary medium
television when people ask how the
picture gets from the studio where I
work to their home I answer it's a
miracle and I leave it of that however
as a journalist and as a person of a
certain age I was just smart enough and
astute enough to recognize that the
introduction first of the personal
computer and then the many-faceted
software programs that drive it and then
of course the explosive expansion of our
reach to the Internet would
fundamentally alter my time and the
world and so it has we are a living in
the midst of the most transformational
technology that I can possibly imagine
what over moreover what is particularly
intriguing to me is that we are at the
dawn of this new age on the cusp of this
era of Technology we're in the seminal
stages of what I call the second Big
Bang when a new universe is being formed
just as our physical universe was formed
by the first Big Bang
we are still at this moment trying to
determine which planets will support
life and which won't
we've already seen some that have
drifted too close to the Sun and burned
up others have merged or hope to to
become more than the sum of their
considerable individual parts some have
grown from a small almost unnoticeable
presence to a powerful force in this new
life form that we all use and through it
all the expansions and the use of the
student technology have been advanced
not by a small collection of monkish
wonks working in a secret lab
but instead by a vast never a larger
population of inventive teenagers
laboratory scientists physicians
academicians business executives
merchants farmers public servants
military analysts in the Pentagon and
there are grunts in the field
environmentalists and geologists
journalists and librarians NGOs and
multinational corporations people of
faith and people who do not believe
every day with the power at their
fingertips and in the bowels of their
servers they know that their world is
limited only by their imagination
historians will look back on this time
as a truly transformational age in the
long history of the world a time when
our planet got much smaller and the
possibilities much larger however the
test of our individual and collective
place in this time is not yet complete
for life is not a virtual experience if
we develop capacity and leave out
compassion what is the reward what are
the consequences if speed overruns
reason when I talk to young people these
days I am inclined to remind them the
global poverty will not be eliminated by
hitting the delete button the climate
change will not be stopped by hitting
backspace it will do us little good to
wire the world if we short circuit our
souls when I am asked as I was just
today who are the most memorable people
that I've met and my more than 45 years
in journalism
most of them expect me to say all the
presidents since John F Kennedy dr.
Martin Luther King Nelson Mandela Nicola
Gorbachev Adele Castro Golda Meir Jonas
Salk Steve Jobs Fellini Pavarotti John
Wayne Marlon Brando Bruce Springsteen
Mia Hamm and because all politics
local Ted Williams and Tom Brady these
are some of the big names that I have
had the privilege of encountering in my
wanderings around the world but in fact
the most memorable people that I have
encountered as a citizen and as a
journalist are those whose names I never
knew brave young black and white civil
rights workers in my youth who went to
the South determined to end the moral
hypocrisy that all people in this
country are created equal by putting
their bodies and their hearts and their
minds in front of racists redneck law
enforcement officers who beat them and
hose them and turn dogs upon them but
they could not be deterred because they
were led by the great courageous leader
and the advocate of non-violence dr.
Martin Luther King who was cruelly
assassinated 40 years ago this week I
remember as well a young man from
Oklahoma a member of Doctors Without
Borders at the height of the anarchy in
Somalia middle of the night we were
under mortar fire he was in a surgical
tent operating on a Somali child badly
wounded by fragments and I said to him
aren't you afraid of being here and he
said of course I am mr. Brokaw I said
then why are you here and he said well
God gave me these abilities I got a
mountain of medical school debt back
home but I thought I should use these
talents as best I can
during these years to save poor children
like this little girl who is on my
operating table now a young Chinese
student who stopped me in the back
alleys of Beijing at the time of
Tiananmen Square and eloquently
described the hopes of his generation
for human rights and fundamental
political rights in that country a New
York fire captain that I encountered in
the bowels of the World Trade Center at
Ground Zero just eight days after those
twin towers were brought down his face
was etched with fatigue and
caked with clay he was looking for the
men who would work for him who had given
their lives that day and he'd been
working ever since the attack 18 19
hours a day he stood in front of me for
a long time without saying anything and
finally he said I read your book their
greatest generation I said thank you
very much he said I didn't really
understand my father or his generation
until I read that book and I'm eternally
grateful to you for doing that
nice - thank you very much and he said I
learned so much about my dad and I
learned something about you and I looked
at him and I said you used to think I
was a communist right and he looked at
me unblinkingly and said no just a
liberal scum and turned and walked away
these are young and old men and women
representing a wide range of ethnicity
and interest unhinged from the comfort
of their homes willing to put their
boots on the ground and put their hands
on the door and spend their nights and
scary places to make this precious
planet a better place for all of us now
when I encounter those unrecognized and
modest heroes around the world as I did
last year in Rwanda and the year before
that and the earthquake ravaged
mountains of northern Pakistan I do find
that they have nuku tools to go with
their quiet courage and their personal
commitment in Rwanda where a program of
national reconciliation is underway
following the devastating genocide of
1994 when neighbor said upon neighbor
and cruelly hacked to death children and
old friends over a three-week period in
which the world simply stood by radio
and Rwanda remains the primary means of
communication for the population but for
the people who are trying to put this
country back together again computers
and databases give them a
and roadmap to the next stage in that
mountainous country of primitive
communication and transportation
infrastructure NGO workers in Africa can
now visit remote villages and instantly
transmit their findings to a central
collection center so Rapid Response
Teams can be dispatched to deal with the
health crisis at hand in Pakistan I
spent the night in a cargo container was
a group of American aid workers they had
been spending six months hiking to
distant and devastated mountain villages
to determine health sanitation housing
and other needs
they were boots on the ground in the
most fundamental sense of that PHA
phrase but their fingers when they got
to the end of the day we're on a
keyboard to speed the process of
rebuilding in a much more efficient
fashion and by the way to make a lasting
impression on those poor souls who
believe that the world has forgotten
them especially the Western world it is
one of the intersections after all of
all that we hold dear here in the
Western world and Muslim fundamentalism
these are new tools that require a human
face as we attempt to diminish and lower
the temperature of Islamic rage a
physician that I know in New York a
specialist in new forms of restoring
hearing to the profoundly death will
soon program the cochlear implant of a
child in East Africa from a computer at
New York University a farmer friend of
mine and the Great Plains
now calibrates his annual planting
program by tracking world market
conditions on a daily basis on his
computer and by eliminating so much of
the guesswork that he is now one of the
many helping revive the agricultural
economy in that central part of the
United States those people that I have
encountered are not found on page six of
the tabloids or on the evening
entertainment shows
however they are the defining generation
of our time because they have learned
how to twin the uses of this technology
with their own personal commitment they
are in many ways the same as a
grandparents and in some cases their
parents who came of age in this country
and the Great Depression and then one
office save the war world in World War
two they were the defining generation of
their time as their offspring the baby
boomers became the vanguard of
liberators of people of color and women
in our society and the inventors of this
astonishing new technology in their use
of it and in their vision for the future
they also recognized a fundamental truth
it takes a guiding hand an imaginative
approach and most of all a good heart
think of another time when the frontier
of Technology was advancing at warp
speed the turn of the 20th century when
man flight was now a possibility when
the first vehicles began to replace
horse-drawn buggies when the telephone
changed communication in America when
medicine began to do more good than harm
to the patient's my god the
possibilities of that era when everyone
was proclaiming the 20th century the
American Century the age of technology
and industrial power and political
goodness as represented by the American
Way of life my god the possibilities and
the horrors of that century which gave
us the two greatest wars in the history
of mankind the introduction of the
nuclear age genocide and an unspeakable
scale in the heart of Western
civilization but also in Africa and Asia
the rise of communism and the cruelest
and most oppressive form new plagues and
old feuds along ancient sectarian lines
now we do live on a smaller planet with
many more people we have been witness to
the limits of military power and we
worry about the widening and potentially
volatile gap between the haves and the
have-nots we see temperature's going up
ice caps and rainforests disappearing
and energy becoming more scarce and more
expensive we have the technology to deal
with all these life-altering
developments but we can never forget
that we also need the will and the
people who will use that greater
technology for the common good moreover
these challenges require an attention
span and of patience longer than the
conventional post on a YouTube a
commitment that goes beyond a quick date
on match.com it is not just the content
of the post and the blog's that require
our attention it is also the source and
the integrity of that which shows up on
the small screen as a journalist with
roots deep in traditional media but with
a realistic understanding of a seismic
change is now underway and the manner in
which we get our daily news how its
gathered distributed and consumed I am
an out writer for the masses who rely on
mass communication my message is this
beware of the unidentified matter that
emerges from the outer reaches of the
blogosphere it may have the weight and
shape of reliable and useful information
but how do we know as an extension of
the second Big Bang that I described a
few moments ago the error of these days
is filled with small meteorites
cascading through the skies and onto the
air and screens of personal computer
users everywhere by mid day much of the
heretofore unheard-of matter takes on
the characteristics of time-tested
material but it could be nothing more
than the product of a rich imagination
it could be simply mischievous or more
ominously it could be malevolent
the means of how we receive the oxygen
of a free people credible information
about their government their culture and
their commerce it is undergoing a
historic transformation what has not
changed is the requirement of society
anywhere in this world to be best served
by information that is gathered and
assembled by trained professionals with
a keen eye and a skeptical mind who go
out the door and into the streets and
into the records and into war zones and
into impoverished areas to report first
hand with their witnessing personally I
of course welcome the small d--
democratic-- characteristics of the
internet and the blogosphere it has
vastly expanded the range of opinion
insight analysis available to even the
most casual user when I was a young man
growing up in a small town in South
Dakota I would get up in the morning
with my mother who was an avid news
watcher and before she went to work and
I went to school we would watch The
Today Show and I would come home at
night and there would be a family
appointment around huntley-brinkley
Walter Cronkite in some households but
we were a huntley-brinkley household on
NBC and we would get a not very good
daily newspaper delivered at the end of
the day now if I were a young man in
that same community and I still have
friends there they get up in the morning
and they log on to the BBC and they have
a wide range of cable offerings on their
television set they exchange messages
with their friends not just in their
community
but around the world and during their
school hours they can stay abreast of
what is going on by going onto their
computer as well and when they get home
at night they can read the New York
Times if they so choose or the London
newspapers or they can read specialty
publications they can go on to the MIT
website and find out what you're doing
with the Energy Initiative or with
cancer research in this great
institution
times have changed the possibilities are
limitless for good
but they are equally great we must
always remember for distortion and fraud
and anarchy at the end of the day in
this breathtakingly exciting time and
which were living most of all what is
required of those of us who live in this
privileged society is a recognition that
we have a moral and intellectual
commitment to leave this precious planet
a better place than we found it by
putting our boots on the ground our
hands in the dirt and spending our
nights and scary places on behalf of our
fellow citizens around the world we're
not as privileged as we are we can all
have cell phones PDAs we can all be
wired or go wireless
but these tools after all should always
be an extension of our hearts as well as
our minds and they should be an
extension of the legacy that we want to
leave we serve our time and our fellow
citizens around the world best by loving
our mother mother earth thank you all
very much
thank you
now I never again will have the
opportunity to stand in the well of an
MIT space looking about out on these
young people whose SAT scores were
probably twice and maybe even three
times what line work and attempting to
answer questions we have some
microphones set up I ask only that you
speak up and state your question clearly
or if it's not a statement try to put a
question mark at the end of your
statement if you would do that please
yes ma'am if you'd go to the microphone
that would be hopeful it's right there I
think it's great to meet you pull it
right down close to you can you hear me
you have to pull it down so I can't just
stand up somebody I just wanted to ask
you if you've thought about running for
president
now I have two answers to that one is
that I'm running for cover I'm not
running for office the other is I you
know it's been flattering I'm happy to
report that I've had inquiries from both
parties from time to time as well as
from several deranged friends suggesting
that I ought to think about running for
public office and my answer the first
serious response is that I chose this
profession journalism because I think
it's honorable and important and I have
worked hard at doing what I hope is an
acceptable job and I think it's
important that I stay on that side of
the fence and the second answer is I'm
not going to run for office because I
don't want my family to move to Canada
which they would do if I were to run for
office yes ma'am
backed up there last January in Rwanda
doing work on water and sanitation in
developing countries and I was wondering
what your impressions of the people were
over there I don't know what year you
were there and how close was the
genocide but your impressions of the
people and how you felt not not the
higher-ups not Kagame but the local
people okay I having a little hard time
understanding then Oh have you been
there yes two months over there yeah
it's it's it's one of the most
remarkable places I've ever been in
terms of how they're trying to come to
grips with the enormous challenge before
them and to do that within the confines
of their country
you know the unspeakable horrors and and
then when you go into a small village in
a remote area and you find the genocide
errors as they call the people who
committed these unspeakable acts sitting
in their prison uniforms at a table
across from someone who they completely
eliminated their family
and they're having this dialogue about
how they can work out their common
future it's at once inspiring and
slightly disorienting frankly I work
with something called the International
Rescue Committee big refugee
organization and we did a lot of a
database stuff of collecting what
attitudes were and I came back kind of
transformed frankly you know I've been
after us a long time I'm pretty hard
shelled but I was deeply moved by what I
saw there and my wife was with me at the
time and there are families involved in
a lot of humanitarian efforts and our
youngest daughter we thought was a
natural to go to Rwanda so we told her
that she should go and she went on a
woman and woman program she's going back
again shortly and it has had the same
impact on her life
I my concern about Rwanda is to take you
a little deeper into the story my
concern about Rwanda is a landlocked
country it doesn't have a lot of Natural
Resources so the economy and economic
revival there is a big task they don't
have the kind of tourism that other
African countries have they have the
gorillas in the north not a lot of them
they have coffee and they're working
hard at improving that as some kind of a
an economic growth engine forum the
president is very impressive and Kagame
and he has been coming in New York and
Seattle a lot in hopes that he can make
Rwanda into a kind of Switzerland of
Africa a financial center because
they're trustworthy and there and there
and their institutions are not corrupt
so I hope that it will work out I also
think it probably will be an object
lesson for NGOs in the world certainly
we have looked at this at IRC we can't
just deal with the effects of these
cataclysmic events that happen like
genocide or terrible storms for that
matter or war we really have to start
dealing with the symptoms of it and we
got behind into our four I say that in a
collective sense or you know that went
on too long and now it's very hard to
put that one back together again
and and the other thing has happened in
this country quite honestly there's
Africa fatigue people are kind of worn
out about hearing about it because the
problems are so monumental at the moment
and there's enormous work being done
it's productive and it's making progress
there's a lot more to be done and in
this country we're distracted by our
presidential election by the economy and
what's going on so that's gonna be on
the agenda for a long time anyhow thanks
for asking about that thank you no other
questions are there any answers actually
I think we have one coming here then
once you come in and stand right behind
him right now hi Tom my name is Martin
Holmes I'm a senior in aerospace
engineering and I want to ask a quick
question
science and technology play an integral
role in society and world affairs and
yet a lot of society seems to take
technology for granted and the
government seems to put less funding
into science and basic research than it
did in the past so I'm wondering what
you think MIT as a university can do to
help improve the situation and what you
as a member of the media can do to shed
light on this issue
well we actually talked about that and
to some degree earlier today and then
such that I had with some students and
then with faculty members who were
working on the cancer project and also
on the energy project I think we're
gonna have to think across the spectrum
and institutions like this and in our
government in a more stateless way and
then the problems that we are now all
here thinking about and talking about
don't stop at the water's edge and we
cannot live in the Western world in the
Western industrial world with a sense of
security I think if we don't begin to do
something about it the undeveloped world
and help them become a rising tide and
so I would hope that there would be a
greater effort across borders in a
stateless fashion
to deal with a lot of these minute I
don't know you can't deal with global
warming by just developing United States
policy that's a purple of it in the same
thing with a lot of the global health
issues we're already seeing that with
AIDS so I think the new administration
politically whoever it is whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat institutions
like MIT and the role the media will
have to rethink how we approach a lot of
these intractable problems and get the
technology that is available available
out there we're doing a much better job
but in you know in a lot of these
countries they're happy when a light
bulb turns on much of us being able to
have what we take for granted on a daily
basis you know it's it's happened quite
swiftly in this country it was not that
many years ago that the personal
computer in our case and our family when
our kids were small we have one of the
little early max you know upstairs it
was pretty primitive and they were
playing pong and I remember thinking god
this is going to change the world in
some ways and the head of the of IBM at
the time came to visit NBC and I said
what do you think the personal computers
future is and he said that my wife does
some writes or invitations to parties on
and so on but I don't see much of a use
for it
and that's the reason that Bill Gates is
one of the richest men in the world
today so that's what I think we do have
to think in a new way in a new form
let's take her and then take you okay
hi I'm Shiva Ozma a recent graduate in
brain and cog but I'm kind of curious
about your comments on how the internet
will affect TV journalism I know there
was a shift from radio journalism to TV
journalism a long time ago and I was
wondering if you could comment on how
you think the internet will be affecting
what our existing TV I need help with
that again because I'm here I'm losing
it up here
we like the internet to go away so we
can go back to being a monopoly again
it's it's listen it's just hard for me
and for most of us who grew up in
traditional media and I think even for
new users of it to understand the impact
of it and where it's going it is it's
limitless in my judgement and we're
racing as fast as we can to try to keep
pace with the changes that are going on
trying to deal with something I touched
on here earlier where does the stuff
come from and how useful is it and how
much can we trust it the quick answer is
in in television in broadcast journalism
we hope that we can take the smaller
screen the computer or the PDA and marry
it to the slightly larger screen the
television and out of that we'll have
something that will work for you and
work for us
newspapers have a larger problem at the
moment there's a story today about the
New York Times and they're under assault
again they're losing revenue at an
alarming rate because people are going
onto the internet to buy things and to
advertise things it's expensive to
gather this information from around the
world which brings me to my last point
the internet has grown up with an
audience that thinks that everything is
free you know one of the early pioneer
is Stewart Brand who founded the Whole
Earth Catalog said information should be
free well that's fine except it costs a
lot to have a Bureau in Baghdad and to
you know to run the satellites that come
out of the political campaign that we
should all know about and to have people
staffing that on a 24/7 basis and so we
all have to have a think about that new
model I like the small d-- democratic--
part of it i like hearing these new
voices that are out there and there's
some brilliant new analysts and
commentators from all over the country
that we wouldn't have heard from without
the internet I like the speed of it in
there and the reach of it
but what I do worry about is how we can
at some point always be able to rely on
people who are trained to gather this
information and put it in a useable
engaging form to vet it if you will so
that when you get it however you get it
it's reliable and useful to you that's
the test and by the way you have a part
in that it's not just up to us
you're the consumers and you have to
apply the same principles to that that
you would to anything else that you're
using that plays a critical part of your
life and so we're all on this one
together thank you sir hi Tom my name is
Alan I'm curious you mentioned the honor
of the profession of journalism do you
feel that it has remained generally an
honorable profession or what needs to
happen if it has slipped to regain some
of that honor that's a many part
question and I get it a lot with good
reason what has happened is the spectrum
is widened so much there are so many
more parts to it and typically it's like
as I often describe it you're going to
300-mile car drive a road trip and
everything goes fine and it goes
splendidly and then you see a three-car
pileup and that's what you want to talk
about when you get to the destination
and when people look at the 24/7 cable
coverage they're more inclined to settle
on that part of the day or that moment
when the wheels came off in some fashion
one way or another one wish there was
something that was irresponsible or
outrageous that was said on the air I
actually like the idea that we have
expanded the spectrum and I think as
consumers you have to be a little more
aggressive about what you look for and
how you find it I personally have found
that we have a lot of good people that
still want to come into journalism I was
just at Columbia last week at the
journalism school and the Clemen who's
running it now has really changed the
model so he has them working a lot
harder in areas like the Academy and
Sciences and liberal arts and making
sure that they get a very broadly based
background
but I did look at these bright young
students and wonder where they're gonna
work at some point so I think it's still
by and large honorable but that there
are some egregious examples of people
who abused the privilege of being a
journalist that's always been the
consequence of having a Free Press look
the early pamphleteers in the 18th
century were pretty wildly or
responsible and if you want to look at
some political covers you ought to go
back and look at 19th century political
coverage one of the when the papers were
extremely partisan and they would print
or say anything to advance the cause of
their particular candidate you know when
I first started it in the business in
the 1950s here in Boston New York Los
Angeles most major major metropolitan
areas had newsracks filled with tabloids
all day long they were simply the print
version of what you see in a lot of
cable television now so again it's up to
each of us to develop a filter of some
kind and say oh that person was worth
listening to that one is not the
outrageous stuff that you see is on the
air in part because people are drawn to
it you know it's a it's a it's kind of a
a commercial compact it doesn't make me
very happy we have an amusing but
unsettling experience in Los Angeles we
sent out a new news director to our Los
Angeles station a very wise woman who
was determined to do only the right
thing in Los Angeles in cover City Hall
and covers state politics and so on and
not cover those mindless car chases on
the freeways that we've all seen so
she'd been there about two weeks big car
chase develops on the 405 every breeze
station in town right now it's a height
of the news hour every station in town
switches to the car chase she said not
us we're gonna stay with the news the
ratings dropped to zero what plummeted
all the way down and it was a big object
lesson for you know about how you're
gonna have to manage that so we all have
a part of him over here can we make this
the last one is that okay I'm impressed
by your poise in dealing with these
bigger picture issues
and it's very inspiring I think it was
Al Gore who said in reference to dealing
with the environmental stuff that it's
very easy to move from denial straight
into essentially a place of fear right I
wonder if you can comment because it's
clear that you've spent so much time in
front of so many big scary things
how do people of lesser strength and
lesser sort of perspective that the
common people how do we deal with these
issues do you have any sort of insight
for that because I find that I'm often
in either a place of denial or fear
around some of the bigger issues in our
culture well to begin with a very
personal perspective part of my role
which was unanticipated when I stepped
down from nightly news at the
organization now is I am what they call
the designated hall monitor I go up and
down the hallways and say now children
let's start paying attention to this and
Chris Matthews did you have to say what
you just said can we just run that by us
everybody again yeah it's a concern
because everything now has a breathless
urgency about it and and part of that is
driven by the need to fill up all this
time you know we've got 24/7 cable we
gotta fill it up with something I
commented earlier that I had hoped I
spent a lot of last year looking at this
model and I was told by everyone that it
would simply not work and that would be
a premium news channel an HBO of news in
which you'd have a consortium of the New
York Times NBC you know maybe the
Financial Times there's a couple of
other traditional outlooks we've put
together this consortium and we charge
you you have a dedicated website and a
dedicated news channel and it cost you a
few bucks but you're probably spending
that money now on newspapers that are
delivered to your door and magazines you
get on a regular basis and everybody
that I talked to including Ted Turner
who is an enormous advocate of getting
more information out there I mean CNN
was not just a business proposition for
him it grew out of his strong sense of a
public citizen that we need to have more
information and he said it won't work
because the cable systems won't carry it
they don't want to take a chance on on
that kind of expense and you've all come
to believe it it's yours for the taking
I have a daughter we're in in our family
and - diminishing businesses I have a
daughter in the music business and I'm
in the news business it's a lot harder
for her she's got a very senior position
at Warner Records and you know all day
every day she gets migraines trying to
figure out how they're gonna make a buck
out of these artists
and what they're gonna do so it's tough
I really have enjoyed this I hope I can
come back some time and see you in
smaller groups thank you all very much
[Applause]